sur le site de la Ravine Blanche on
peaufine on affine le chantier depuis
quelques jours les techniciens les
bénévoles et les artisans sont à pieds
d'oeuvre on vérifie l'électricité les 5
scènes se montent-ils en petits lampes
même s'il est préparatifs de la 19e
édition sont bien rodées les
responsables restent prudents face à la
routière dans la sécurité on n'aime pas
les habitudes donc on est extrêmement
vigilant par rapport à ça donc quand je
dis sécurité c'est pas forcément
sécurité gardiennage c'est aussi
l'ensemble des structures qui sont
montées que ce soit les tentes les
chapiteaux les plateformes et les scènes
bien sûr peu de changements par rapport
aux éditions précédentes excepté cette
scène 360 degrés t-board en the beach on
a complètement remodifié le site pour
pouvoir accueillir plus de monde
en zone VIP et en zone publique on a
fluidifier tout le site pour que ça
puisse vraiment bien circuler et voilà
en fait on est prêt à attendre jusqu'à
15000 personnes
depuis la semaine dernière les artisans
de l'association simanga vol tresse les
200 feuilles de coco sur les trois jours
12 groupes défileront dans la salle
verte le poumon du festival
pour que la cuisine c'est Serge
à Ludovic namichelin
arrive le son et
là on attend de finit à salvet
comme il faut là juste le bon petit
dernier détail manque et après les
parties pour ça même avec 30000 billets
déjà vendus cette année les
organisateurs s'attendent à une
fréquentation historique un bol d'air
car il faut rembourser les dettes liées
à la gestion de la crise covid
dorénavant une soirée au festival
coûtera 45 euros pour venir découvrir 15
groupes moins cher c'est plus possible
pour nous
on a maintenu la politique tarifaire
pendant très longtemps et c'est
absolument impossible il faudrait
trouver beaucoup d'autres choses alors
après à côté de ça on développe tout un
tas d'opérations avec des partenaires
sur des publics cibles on va dire un peu
plus en difficulté donc avec qui
on mène des opérations et on essaie de
faire en sorte que le prix soit moins
impactant je pense au public de
proximité sur le quartier de la Ravine
Blanche avec le soutien de la schlmr par
exemple 15000 places reste à vendre coup
d'envoi les premières notes dans deux
jours